hallo andreas meine frage an dich ist
was nicht zu dem lied nur in meinem kopf
veranlasst hat und ob du je gedacht
hättest dass dieser so berühmt wird
danke für deine antwort und vielleicht
sieht man sich ja mal liebe grüße wie
kam es dazu die nummer ist ist
tatsächlich entstanden einfach weil ich
bin ganz begeistert von fantasie dass
wir diese gabe besitzen
und fantasie ist ein ganz wichtiger
grundstoff für ideen und kreativität und
ich fand es ganz wichtig dass man als
kind ja ganz verschiedene sachen sich
auch immer wünschen dass man das gerne
fliegen möchte fliegen möchte dass man
zum beispiel durch wände gehen kann um
sichtbar zu sein oder die zeit eben
anzuhalten und ich habe diese ganzen
dinge und die strophen eingebaut und was
diese begeisterung heraus dass man in
seinen gedanken alles machen kann und es
da keine grenzen gibt ist nur in meinem
kopf entstanden und dass die nummer so
erfolgreich würde das hat mich der
christopher folgen eigentlich schon
gefragt und das wusste ich natürlich
nicht das weiß man ja nie ich hatte
zuerst diese nummer tatsächlich auch
überhaupt nicht als single eigentlich
gedacht gehabt und hat er aber später
dann als ich das so ein paar freunden
und leuten folge spielte angesagt das
müsste unbedingt machen als erstes und
dann habe ich dann jetzt auch so gemacht